[Musique]
il y à des images qui semblent tout
droit sortis de notre époque pourtant
c'était il ya moins de deux ans
[Musique]
il est roux venait d'être élu mais
minoritaire
sans obtenir une solution en alberta et
en saskatchewan
le grand enjeu à ce moment là le webzine
l'aliénation de l'ouest peut-être donum
donc son bras droit sa star pour rebâtir
les ponts avec les conservateurs des
accusés du rhdp par le choc très vite
d'autres cris souffre à
un avion s'écrase en iran avec 63
canadiens à bord des manifestants
bloquent des voies ferrées soutien au
wat souhaitait pour s'opposer à un
projet de gazoduc
puis un jour de mars un virus qui
semblait bien lointain circonscrit à une
ville chinoise du bout du monde commence
à faire des ravages au canada une fois
dedans
combien en quelques jours tout le pays
est paralysé combat au pays est passé à
la vitesse supérieure
ottawa demande à tous les canadiens
d'éviter petit lpil épouse du premier
ministre justin trudeau est infecté par
l'aco vite 19 on a tous un rôle à jouer
dans la lutte contre la corée de 19 le
premier ministre en quarantaine
préventives et contraint de s'adresser
aux médias de chez lui merci tout le
monde il ne le sait pas encore mais
cette formule est là pour rester devant
le désarroi généralisée justin trudeau
sort le chéquier pour les entreprises la
politique économique canadienne la plus
importante depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale et pour les canadiens qui ont
perdu leur emploi
en voulant aider justement les libéraux
tribu il octroie la gestion d'un
programme de bourses aux étudiants à une
pourtant la famille trudeau est liée à
l'organisme celle du ministre des
finances aussi le premier nice s'est
comporté de façon
d'indicateurs je pense que le premier
ministre soit simplement faire un pas de
côté au final c'est bill morneau qui
tire sa révérence au mois d'août dernier
je démissionnerai de mon poste mais
l'est finances
et une controverse n'attend pas l'eau
julie payette que justin trudeau avait
fièrement nommé gouverneur général est
visé par des allégations d'intimidation
et d'humiliation et malheureusement sa
porte la signature de monsieur trudeau
scandale à le finir par éclabousser
justin trudeau quelques mois plus tard
ce seront les plus hauts gradés de
l'armée qui seront la cible
d'allégations cette fois-ci d'inconduite
sexuelle voulant tourner la page et
libéraux dans la deuxième année de leur
mandat multiplie les engagements
progressiste c'est clair que tout le
monde va devoir faire plus avec un plan
environnemental plus ambitieux et
l'annoncent d'un programme national de
garderies au coup de tête sans avenir
mais encore une fois l'actualité est
dominée par la pandémie les contrôles
aux frontières et surtout par la course
au vaccin
après plusieurs retards au début les
livraisons d'eau s'accélère permettent à
justin trudeau de tenir sa fameuse
promesse aujourd'hui je peux vous
annoncer que le canada a maintenant reçu
assez de vaccins contre la coved 19 pour
que toutes les personnes admissibles
puissent être pleinement d'accident mais
au bout du compte est-ce que c'est cet
accomplissement les électeurs
retiendrons de deuxième mandat la
gestion de la pandémie permettra-t-elle
d'aller au delà des controverses des
déficits records et des grands chantiers
inachevés comme la réconciliation qui
sont d'ailleurs revenus hanter le chef
libéral durant les derniers mois la
réponse dans quelques semaines
[Musique]